Tell her to continue talking about air
quality today and air quality law and,
uh,
also to,
make some comments about women versus
American trucker in response to a couple
of questions.
So with respect to Whitman,
uh,
EPA in 1997 had proposed
new pm and ozone standards,
uh,
and both the northeastern states and
California supported these measures and a
members from Congress from the
Midwestern states did not support it.
This is quite common with
their quality standards.
It was unprecedented in a eps history
for a single change in a national ambient
air quality standard.
Have 28 days of hearings in Congress.
And finally,
this was brought to court and made its
way to the court of appeals and the DC
circuit.
And the circuit found that the
standards were unconstitutional,
was eventually elevated
up to the Supreme Court.
And I read you,
uh,
the conclusion of the Supreme Court and,
but they also a raised a separate question
about the consideration of costs and
whether or not costs should be part of
the calculus a and section 109 B one
instructs the EPA to set primary
ambient air quality standards,
uh,
the attainment and maintenance of which
are requisite to protect public health
will inadequate margin of safety.
That seems rather clear.
However,
they went on saying that,
uh,
the respondent's argue,
that many more factors than air
pollution affect public health.
In particular,
the economic costs of implementing a
very stringent standard might produce
health losses sufficient to offset the
health gains achieved and cleaning the
air,
for example,
by closing down whole industries and
thereby impoverishing the workers and
consumers dependent upon those industries.
So this is unquestionably true.
And the congress was unquestionably
aware of it at the time.
Uh,
and considering the role of economics
and decision making and how that might be
balanced against a estimates of risk and
the benefits from a tougher air quality
regulations.
Uh,
the court continued,
uh,
Congress has commissioned,
had commissioned in the air quality
act of 1967 a detailed estimate of the
economic impact of air quality
standards on the nation's industries,
communities,
and other contributing
sources of pollution.
The 1970 congress not only
anticipated the compliance costs,
uh,
that could injure the public health,
but provided for that
precise [inaudible] exigency,
excuse me.
Exigency
and the section one 10 of the clean air
act permitted the administrator to waive
the compliance deadline for stationary
sources if sufficient control measures
were simply a unavailable
and the continued operation
of such sources who was
found to be essential to the
public health or welfare.
And it a section,
uh,
two oh two prescribed the
emission standards for
automobiles could take effect
only after such a period
that the administrator finds
necessary to permit the
development and application of the
requisite technology giving appropriate
consideration to the cost of
compliance within such period.
So Epa could decide that it's time
for a new air quality standard,
but they could find that the
economic effects were so intense,
uh,
that,
they could delay that.
Uh,
and,
and to offer the industry
the opportunity to retool,
reorganize in order to develop
by the necessary technology,
say a new,
uh,
mission control system in order
to meet that new standard.
So despite this consideration of costs,
uh,
the court found that the engine driving
nearly all of title one is section one
oh nine B one.
And I commend you to read this.
Uh,
you can call it up on [inaudible] website,
uh,
that these standards have to be set to
protect public health with this margin of
safety to account for uncertainty
and the risk estimate.
So when interpreting the statutory text,
Congress does not one might say
hide elephants and mouse holes.
So they overturned the appellate ruling.
I don't want to take you back to a
where I left you a on Tuesday and talk a
little bit more about asthma and,
and,
uh,
the,
the prevalence of asthma and
the finding by Mark Colon.
Uh,
and Eileen story at the University of
Connecticut that between three and 22% of
kids in Connecticut schools,
I had been diagnosed by physicians.
And by the way,
the,
uh,
one of the gold standards for,
recognizing an illness and a population
would be looking at whether or not it
had,
had been diagnosed by a
physician and in schools.
It's interesting that if,
if your child is on any medication,
other then you have to register those
medications with the school nurse.
So the school nurse has to
keep a very tight control,
uh,
in fact,
they,
they maintain the meds in
the nurse's offices so that,
uh,
this is a really interesting and important
than high quality method of record
keeping.
So mark and I and several others wondered
together about what the causes of the
rise in asthma might have been
during the 1980s in 1990s.
And we started thinking about what had
changed and whether or not kids might be
exposed to different kinds of chemicals.
Uh,
and I left you also with uh,
uh,
this lung section and I want it to come
back to this because I didn't explain it
very carefully the other day.
Uh,
so on the left is basically rat lung
tissue exposed to low concentrations of
diesel exhaust.
And what you see is the coagulation,
uh,
between,
cells of the particulate matter,
the carbon,
uh,
in those that are exposed
at higher concentrations.
Now,
what this suggests is that,
that,
uh,
you might think about scenarios that
would lead to higher levels of exposure.
So what might those be?
Well,
we're talking about black
carbon in this case.
So,
uh,
when are people more exposed
to combustion byproducts?
Uh,
so the,
one of the,
one of the things you should always think
about in terms of those that are more
exposed would be occupational settings.
So how about for example,
minors?
So in coal mines,
uh,
the coal dust is also carbon dust,
but also they use diesel generators
to provide electricity to,
uh,
basically,
give energy to,
to,
uh,
the jackhammers and a to the
lighting that they have in the minds.
So the combination of
unventilated a diesel generator,
fumes on top of the coal
dust leads to high exposures.
And what about,
uh,
what about truck drivers?
It was interesting after the study that
I'm going to review with you in a few
moments.
Uh,
I received a,
a phone call from someone who had seen
it and they wondered whether or not they
should get involved.
This was the,
the American Federation of Labor,
the AFL CIO.
Uh,
they were concerned that,
that,
uh,
they were an organization of truck drivers
that really might be one of the more
highly exposed groups,
highly exposed because they sit
inside their trucks all day long.
Uh,
and especially in,
in urban areas where,
where traffic comes to a standstill,
you could expect that the
exposures would be highest.
So occupational settings are clearly
a one area where people might be more
heavily exposed.
A couple other human lung tissue samples
that I wanted to show you with respect
to black carbon,
uh,
actually only one.
So bringing you back to,
uh,
the,
the map and the concept of,
of the way that we understand the air
pollution problem is really driven by
these dots on this map.
We could be in any state in the nation
and you'd see a similar kind of map with,
with the monitoring
stations scattered about.
Uh,
and in some instances
they have a concentration,
uh,
where they think that the,
the,
uh,
ambient concentrations are our highest,
so that you can see them down along
the southeastern part of the coast.
Uh,
and this is the area that
is out of compliance.
It's a non attainment zone
for both particulate matter
and ozone and also up in
the Hartford area.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you see,
a collection of monitors.
Uh,
but it also also,
they are trying to figure out the,
uh,
the,
the variability in
distribution of pollution.
So they put monitors also in parts of the
state that are less densely populated.
So thinking about this,
a group of us decided that we
really wanted to understand,
uh,
what the air was like and if kids day.
So rather than relying on,
on,
uh,
the,
the reports from these
different monitoring stations,
you know,
what if we took a monitors and we put
them on children and then we followed them
at,
through their daily routine from the
time they left home to the time that they
came back to their house after,
after school.
So a group of us,
uh,
including David Brown from,
the,
the Centers for Disease Control and,
uh,
Nancy Alderman who runs a group
called environment and human health,
Mark Colon,
Susan Adams,
the former commissioner of health and
Connecticut and Bob Low camera who's a
professor,
professor of pediatrics here.
Uh,
this was the group that took this study
on along with some technical analysts at
Yukon that,
that run the,
the,
uh,
EPA testing lab.
So all of the air quality measurements
that are taken in the state,
uh,
go through their,
their laboratory too,
to make sure that a,
they're,
they're carefully analyzed.
And I also left you with
this chart so that you could,
you could,
uh,
keep in mind the idea that you've got
a temporal variation in ambient outdoor
air quality that appears to be a
driven and perhaps predictable,
not just by month of the year,
uh,
but also by hour of the day.
So what would these have monitors?
Like here's a,
an example,
a,
a gas canister,
a little,
uh,
metal globe,
that,
uh,
was pulling in air at a preset rate.
It had a vacuum in it and a,
so that we were looking for about 55
different volatile organic compounds that
we knew,
uh,
we're part of,
of diesel emissions.
And by the way,
we,
we weren't really sure whether or not,
uh,
the,
exposure was highest,
uh,
during,
the,
uh,
travel to school or whether or not
their exposure and their risk would be
highest within the school.
Uh,
so we,
we used a variety of different pieces of
equipment that could monitor chemicals
that might be more concentrated
either in traffic or,
or an indoor environments
and in indoor environments.
What kinds of chemicals
might you be concerned about?
Well,
it could be a,
say the chemicals in a
photography laboratory or a
chemistry laboratory such as
a benzine or,
or other solvents.
Or it might be,
uh,
other kinds of cleaning products
or it could be pesticides so that,
uh,
we,
we tried to figure this out in a way
that would point us to the most risky
sources of exposure and with
respect to particulate matter,
these carbon particles.
Uh,
this was the chart that we produced.
By the way,
part of the story is that,
uh,
this is my daughter when
she was about 12 years old.
And so she was the first
Guinea pig she agreed to,
to carry this a voc,
a canister,
but also she has a formaldehyde pump
sitting here on her jacket and a,
she's got a particle meter here
strapped to her belt and she carried a,
uh,
an ID card that had a carbon monitor on
Ethel amateur that's about the size of a
microwave.
So she walked around with this thing,
uh,
by her side all day long.
And a,
as a,
as a rather,
uh,
an amusing anecdote on the side.
When she first stepped on a bus,
all the kids in the back
of the bus screamed,
uh,
because of our post 11 sensitivity
about what people might look like,
all strapped up in technical equipment.
The bus driver threw her off the bus,
and that's when I realized that I should
have called the superintendent and a
warn them what we were doing.
So here's the,
here's the,
uh,
outcome of,
of,
uh,
our initial tests.
Uh,
we found that there was a burst
of exposure early in the day,
uh,
to pm 10 and a also a burst of
exposure at the end of the day.
But there are also a increases that we
saw during the middle of the day that
really were not explained.
And it took us a little
while to figure it out.
But,
uh,
the,
the kind of of of,
uh,
particles that we were
measuring a varied by we're the,
we're the,
the,
uh,
the child was,
so if they're waiting for
the bus or they're on the,
on the school bus,
one could presume that
these were carbon particles.
Uh,
but if they're just a in the,
in the gym,
uh,
moving around,
these could be dust particles.
So if I had a chalkboard up here and
I could take an eraser and just pat it
against the board,
you'd see a cloud of park
pm 10 particulate matter 10,
uh,
move up into the air.
The same thing with a,
a gymnasium where you have,
I say,
yeah,
50 kids running around
playing basketball or,
or,
uh,
some of the sport you get to
particles moving into the air.
So we needed to,
to discern the carbon particles
from other kinds of particles.
So 6,000,
600,000 school buses exist
in the United States.
Uh,
and we also face the problem of
trying to figure out whether or not,
uh,
exposure during those high periods,
early in the day and late in
the day were the result of,
of,
uh,
going to school and traffic from the
buses or were they the particles coming
from other vehicles?
So I'll tell you a bit more
about that in just a moment.
So here's a,
a very quick summary of this study that
was picked up by a good morning America
when it was released.
Now expected to get the FDA approval.
But now we turn back to the story.
Important News for anyone.
One second.
Children who ride school
buses later today,
a new study from Yale University will
be released saying the amount of diesel
fuel
standard and those few are
going on the record in the area.
Yeah,
we need it
most.
Yeah.
You can get those children on APP as
an estimated 180 hours every year.
Uh,
according to a new game university
study by Professor John Parker
[inaudible] off using both
the sensitive monitor,
which he places directly
on school children took
[inaudible] rolling around with
children.
I have full day.
You found out exactly what
[inaudible] water goes.
We've showed just slides
and the management of the
diesel off at certain points
of the day is we jumped to different,
those are the EA,
the EA measure,
air quality location.
An advocate is the results
or what were you hearing?
How much higher than the
government's acceptable.
Where you finding routinely or
for short periods is common?
We're finding levels that were five
to 10 times higher than the government
standard.
That's his biggest fight.
Uh,
it was a surprise to me.
There's no telling exactly what
exposed you to this kind of,
these leads off the,
do you have job?
No,
but children with asthma,
like 30 year old Aaron,
I don't know.
They feel it every time
they get on their boss.
Did you ever had a time when you had
gotten the Buffy and gray and got off the
bus deal and said
her father John does that say,
man,
we're doing something right now
with harmful to our children.
Let's wait five more years before
we were in the parents on stank.
But that's exactly what the EPA is
doing and 2006 there's only to implement
nuclear standard for all
diesel engine and clearly
the research little any layer standards.
And in part they say because diva leads
off is likely the cause of lung cancer
and they say the regulations will prevent
more than 8,000 premature deaths and
more than 300,000 asthma attacks
and want to go do use two devices,
one measure gas with light bending and
the other measure side part of us such
as,
so mark,
go ahead.
15 schools Yelder and carry these
devices throughout their school days.
What we found was,
uh,
when it looks close to a
higher intensity particulars,
but we tend to diminish
during the school day
also found the level
of [inaudible] office.
The,
the buses was especially I under certain
conditions such as when the buses were
parked end to end in front
of the school with the engine
exhaust.
All of us.
Yes,
absolutely.
That's a school bus.
Industry says there's an earlier study
conducted in a Virginia School district
last March that shows really the air on
Fairfax County public schools for poses.
No health risks.
I was one thing was causing your feelings.
Uh,
don't feel along with weight and make
sure we understand everything before we
make decisions that affect the health
of workflows and our unhelpful cells.
Another industry group,
diesel technology forum argues that the
diesel engines now they produce are much
cleaner than the diesel
engines of the path.
And that with the proper
name is easiest to buses,
no threat,
the rights
and costly process of
upgrading on the march.
But give it poses a challenge
to cash strapped punks and
even move the cash.
It will still take your time.
I could send the corresponding
great hundred joins us now.
So your parents,
you've seen this,
you want to do something that you bought.
Well the best thing about the Margot
says that schools can do and the good and
California to do it in
stages like cad getting his,
having a no either policy but school was
holes up they not and why not kicking
out all that diesel
exhaust and other thing.
They can do a staggered at
times but the buses to connect.
So instead of all of
them pulling up the kids,
getting on,
all of them pulling off,
they standard at times,
they kind of,
and it will no problem.
He says it's going to
be kind of expensive.
Retrofitting some of these
buses in five to $6,000.
It would take time.
What's more important?
A couple of asides,
when we were both standing
on the school bus,
there was a film crew there
with about six people.
Uh,
the,
the fumes were,
it was a day actually like this
with a high level of humidity.
Uh,
all of us got sick.
All of us got sick within a
matter of about five minutes.
And,
uh,
it was curious because a,
the consumer correspondent,
Greg Hunter,
he didn't believe that a,
we were really picking up
chemicals that were dangerous.
Uh,
but after,
uh,
after he and the entire
crew felt nauseous and,
uh,
we all got headaches,
because we had lined the buses up one
in front of another and we were the
emissions.
We're basically just building up as,
as,
uh,
the time went by.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
he was clearly convinced that
this was a more serious problem.
So I want to take you back
to the averaging issue and
remember that there's this
24 averaging 24 hour averaging requirement
over three years that's in play with
this standard.
And that was represented by the
graph that I showed you yesterday.
If you took the data that we produced
a for just one child as an example,
then you average it over a
one hour or over eight hours.
You see that,
uh,
all of the levels would be reduced.
So your,
your image of,
of,
uh,
you know,
what the levels were would
be down in this low range,
uh,
missing,
experiences have a much higher pollution.
So again,
the averaging issue played out in,
in the way that,
that,
uh,
we had to think about
different kinds of strategies.
The other issue that I wanted
to bring to your attention,
uh,
that,
that surprised me was that that,
uh,
the amount of time,
the amount of exposure was far
higher than I could have imagined.
So this diagram just shows you that,
that,
uh,
the,
the millions of hours per year spent
on buses by kids in different states.
And I want to point to just a couple of
states here in New York has the highest
amount of time spent by
a child hours on a bus,
uh,
because,
predominantly because,
uh,
of the rural parts of New York and the
relatively high population in New York.
Uh,
but compare that to California,
a California has a,
a little bit less than,
than a half of the hours
or the total exposure,
uh,
the New York.
Now,
why might that be?
Anybody have an,
sorry,
there's more cars.
Okay.
Well,
remember the population of
California is 40 million people.
So it's a much larger
population than New York.
And I think that,
that,
uh,
the,
the answer is likely to be the way that,
uh,
residential populations and,
and communities in California are more
closely clustered together than they are
in New York state.
So it also,
if you find what we found was
that in in places like Idaho,
Wyoming,
and Alaska,
uh,
that it's very common
for kids to spend two,
three hours a day on buses as
opposed to here in Connecticut,
maybe an hour at most
45 minutes to an hour.
So the pattern of land use really was
driving the pattern of exposure that vary
quite a bit state by state.
And one other aspect of this that,
uh,
was,
was important was that the kids
that have disabilities and they,
they might be disabled for a
whole array of different reasons,
but kids that are disabled or
often a bust to regional districts,
a regional school systems that
have very specialized expertise.
So,
uh,
on average,
kids with disabilities
that are moved around to a,
to benefit from the specialized expertise,
uh,
they experience a higher
level of exposure.
Uh,
some,
some kids spend three or four hours per
day going back and forth between these
control centers.
And I mentioned earlier in the term that,
that,
uh,
I got a call from a woman in Alaska
who a wondered about her child who was,
uh,
only three years old who she put
just behind the driver's seat.
She was the driver of the bus.
Uh,
the child was asthmatic and,
and,
uh,
she was having trouble
controlling the asthma,
uh,
with medications.
And she wonder whether or not the
school bus might be a problem.
So I asked her,
well,
how long is it is a,
your,
your daily routine,
how long does your child spend on the bus?
And it was eight and a half hours per day.
So that,
uh,
thinking about these
high end exposures and,
and we're,
uh,
which groups in the population might be
susceptible is an important aspect of
this.
So just one other thing that,
uh,
was,
was interesting in terms of study design.
And again,
in terms of sampling strategy,
first of all,
we were monitoring individual
kids and individual buses.
Uh,
and I just want to reinforce again,
the importance of,
of thinking about sampling strategy.
And remember the little,
uh,
200 mile radius from the Nevada test site
when the atomic energy commission set
up their sampling design.
And in that way,
and how everybody was
fooled into thinking that,
tell those particles
wouldn't go beyond that,
that area.
There's another defect in a scientific
thinking that that led to two a confusion
in this case.
Uh,
we,
we really didn't understand whether
or not the level of pollution,
uh,
was a,
that we were measuring was
coming from inside the bus,
uh,
from other traffic or from,
from,
uh,
other sources.
And a recall the other day,
I said,
well,
you know,
within Connecticut,
we three times as much diesel
fuel indoors to heat heat our,
our,
our buildings,
uh,
compared to what's submitted from,
from vehicles.
Uh,
so it was very important to us too,
to get a sense of,
of what was actually coming out of a bus.
So we set up a separates experimental
bus route in a very rural part of
Connecticut that was far away from any
residential unit or any other source of
carbon that we could think
of other than carbon.
That's kind of moving long distance,
uh,
and,
existing at low levels.
So we would look at our meters
and see that the levels were,
were,
uh,
close to,
to zero.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this was reflected also in the
states monitoring facilities.
Uh,
and then we turned the buses on and we
saw an immediate jump in the particular
account and also in the voc emissions,
uh,
within the buses.
After we did that,
we also saw a couple of
interesting patterns.
And,
uh,
my daughter for example,
was it was on a school bus.
She,
she was picked up,
uh,
near my house and she was taken to
school and there's this increase in
concentration,
which is kind of curious.
And then as she got to a school where
she got off the bus for about 10 minutes
or five minutes until she was
transferred to another bus,
she walked about 50
yards away from the bus,
uh,
and then got back on the next bus and
picked her up and took her eventually to
school.
So,
uh,
this was pretty good.
A pretty good demonstration that,
that,
uh,
that the air quality
within the bus itself was,
was a serious,
a source of exposure.
We also found a kind of curiously,
if we looked at kind of the,
the horizontal movement,
uh,
and we also looked at the,
the uh,
uh,
behavioral pattern that we could,
we could figure out that a elevation
change across a root made a difference in
the particle level within the bus cabin.
So it was a bus went uphill.
It's underload,
uh,
it produces more pollution.
Ah,
emissions are quite a bit higher both
for [inaudible] as well as for for uh,
uh,
the small particles.
In fact,
I was a,
I was coming to work the other day in,
in traffic and uh,
there was a truck next to me and uh,
the truck was using his,
his engine as a brake.
So we would accelerate and traffic.
And I was,
I was right behind this
bus accelerate and traffic.
I could see the dark
black smoke coming out,
meaning the engine is under load and
it's not operating very efficiently.
And then the traffic in front
of the truck would slow down.
And he would use his,
his engine to break the truck.
It was under load again.
And then you see the
black smoke come up again.
So I remember that a cruising
speed that at about 65,
70 miles an hour is the most
efficient level of combustion for,
for most diesel trucks and vehicles.
And by the way,
I don't think I mentioned
this the other day,
there are about 90 million
diesel trucks and vehicles,
uh,
in the United States today.
So this problem is much bigger than
just the 600,000 school buses that,
that,
uh,
I'm looking at in this study,
we also found that if we compare the
level of exposure to the kids on the bus
inside the cabin,
uh,
and to the federal standard,
that they were experiencing levels
that were quite a bit higher,
uh,
sometimes 20 to 25 times higher,
on it for short periods of time.
And then we found this kind
of a curious thing that,
uh,
an idling vehicle,
collects more pollution inside the cabin,
then a,
a moving vehicle.
So there's a ventilation process
that did occur is when a vehicle,
one vehicle moves,
unless the vehicle is
moving in a train of a bus,
our buses that are
coming into a school or,
or,
or leading a school.
By the way,
most vehicles have,
have no filtration system.
Most trucks and buses have no
filtration system for the air,
uh,
in,
in the,
uh,
indoor cabin.
And by the way,
if you get to the point where
you want to buy a new car,
I would really encourage you to think
carefully about the relative quality of
air filtration.
There's some vehicles now the Japanese
vehicles started to put filtration
equipment in first.
Uh,
but it,
it makes a significant difference
to the quality of the indoor air.
You can test that in a kind
of an interesting way with
respect to particulates
and carbon.
Cause you can just take your finger and
they don't clean your dashboard for six
months,
for example.
And then just take your finger and wipe
it across and you'll pick up a variety
of,
of particles that will
come in because of the,
the interior cabinet
is so poorly filtered.
So this,
this idling issue,
uh,
prompted us to think,
well,
you know,
one no brainer as a policy response
would be to try to get the bus drivers to
shut their engines off
while they were idling.
This is a much harder problem to crack
with respect to two trucks because trucks
today,
uh,
are commonly,
on their,
their ignition is switched on
a 24 hours a day because the,
the,
uh,
engine itself is providing electricity
through a generator to refrigerate the,
the,
uh,
cargo,
but it's also providing
electricity for the main cabin.
Uh,
and for some long distance haulers,
especially independent operators,
you know,
they basically live in their trucks.
They will pull over to the side of the
Mcdonald's and sleep for six or eight
hours,
or the pull into a truck stop.
And most truck stops are not equipped
with these electronic outlets so that they
could plug their truck in
and turn their engine off.
So they're burning fuel,
uh,
almost 24 hours a day and island and the,
the,
the level of emissions are higher,
uh,
in the engine while it's idling.
But also I think that,
uh,
the,
the truck drivers exposure is,
is really quite a serious issue.
So we also found that the,
uh,
the filtration equipment in,
in these buses that were built in,
in year 2000 [inaudible] was so poor.
It virtually,
it was large enough the,
the little spaces in the airflow,
we're large enough so that you could
stick a pencil point through it.
Uh,
so clearly it wasn't going to give
any protection at all for low diameter
particulate matter pm 10 or pm 2.5.
So there are a variety of factors
here that you can read an influence,
the degree of concentration and whether
or not the windows are open or whether
or not they're closed the engine type,
the age of the,
the uh,
uh,
engine in the bus so that older buses
are more polluting than the newer buses
are.
[inaudible].
And a one curious thing
about this was whenever I,
whenever I do a study,
I always assume that
I'm going to get sued.
And I was assuming that the large
diesel manufacturing companies were,
we're uh,
uh,
going to give me a pretty rough ride.
And I was really quite surprised
because they wanted to promote my work.
They were really interested in having
this become very common knowledge.
And why might that be,
sorry,
sell new engines.
That's exactly the answer.
They were interested in
selling new engines that
would emit lower levels of the
particles that we were measuring.
And uh,
you know,
put that idea together with the
fact that most trucks have a,
a,
an active lifespan of three
to 4 million miles and,
and often 30 to two,
sometimes even 35 years.
So they were anxious that the standards
be lowered so that they could sell more
vehicles.
So there are a variety of,
of lessons here.
Uh,
we were also measuring
emissions with when,
uh,
the vehicles we're using,
on sulfur content and the fuel
that was 500 parts per million.
And remember I told you the other day
that now the ultra low sulfur fuels are
available and in use,
uh,
as a requirement completely
phased in in the nation,
uh,
as well as has a,
a particle traps that will take out
some of the compounds of concern.
Now,
as you're thinking about this as a policy
problem and then you're thinking about
it with respect to the clean air act,
you should also think about different
parts of the country that are either
within or are out of
compliance with our standards.
So the,
these exposures that are,
are being experienced by,
by kids or,
or the drivers,
they're coming on top of
background air quality problems.
In other words,
the,
uh,
if you look here in Connecticut,
you see that,
uh,
we are a southern part of Connecticut.
We are in an orange where we're exceeding
a the eight hour ozone standard.
Uh,
and we were also,
uh,
when we were doing the study exceeding
the particulate matter standard as well,
so that,
uh,
on a day like this,
you get many of the particles
being rained out of the air,
but on a still humid day,
in the middle of the summer,
you're going to get a very
high level background.
Ambient has called ambient exposure.
So that these,
these,
uh,
within the bus exposures,
or you could imagine other kinds
of pollutants in your daily life,
they're coming on top of this
background level of exposure.
I was also quite surprised to find that,
uh,
diesel particles are measurable,
in any building in the nation.
There's an ambient background
level of diesel particles,
uh,
even in this room as we were able
to discern just the other day.
But,
uh,
I can't smell diesel
exhaust in the room today.
Uh,
but if you had a,
the,
the latest and most sensitive
detection equipment,
uh,
you could smell it.
So we're all experiencing this
background level of exposure.
So I'm,
you know,
one way of thinking about it is how many
hours on the bus is going to lead to
two,
what kind of a total exposure and a,
so if the,
the blue here is represented
and representative of,
of the background level of exposure,
maybe 18,
17,
18,
uh,
micrograms per cubic meter of pm 2.5,
then these other bus exposures in the
colored segments are coming on top of
that.
So if you look way over on
the right for our child,
it's on a bus for three hours,
they would be experiencing,
uh,
the,
the level of pollution that would be
twice with the federal standard is.
So as you're thinking about how to
create a health protective standard,
uh,
you need to think about these ambient
average background levels that are being
picked up and measured by,
by the fixed monitoring equipment.
But also think about just how daily
behavior leads people to be exposed and in
very different ways.
Now also,
it's curious that the European Union
is moving much more rapidly to,
to promote diesel vehicles and,
and diesel engines,
uh,
predominantly to reduce co two emissions.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
diesel now represents about 20%
of the Europeans passenger fleet,
whereas in the United States
it represents less than 3%.
So that,
uh,
it,
it presents a real dilemma
too to think through.
Do we want to reduce co two or do we
want to be more concerned about lowering
the level of exposure to
these particular dates?
So,
you know,
these kinds of questions can,
can lead to policy recommendations,
uh,
and for any kind of a problem.
I want to encourage you to think about,
first of all,
you know,
what's the right target for your,
your proposal is that
the federal government,
state government,
local governments,
uh,
would it be a,
a voluntary standards that you might
encourage to the corporations that
manufacture these,
these products?
Uh,
or what could you recommend to an
individual to reduce their exposure today?
Kind of curiously in response
to that last question.
Uh,
many parents responded to this study
that got much more publicity than it
deserves in terms of
the investment of money.
This study costs about,
uh,
probably 30,
a 30 to $35,000 to,
to,
uh,
to do,
but people all over the country
stopped driving their kids to school,
which was a problem.
Uh,
so I had to,
to come up with some press releases,
uh,
that,
demonstrated that the congestion at some
schools was increasing because people
were not putting their kids on the bus.
Uh,
and it was also increasing the risk of
injury from accidents at the schools so
that,
uh,
driving your,
your kids to school is
not the right answer.
You get a,
you know,
many more,
many more vehicles arriving at the school,
creating a pollution that would be,
uh,
a higher than the quote
would be coming from the bus.
So recommendations to
the federal government,
a retrofit diesel buses with two to
ensure lower put particle traps on them.
And as the,
uh,
the film segment showed
a that's expensive,
that cost about $6,000 per vehicle to do.
Uh,
and it's,
it's an important issue in,
in some of of the states and the federal
government have really stepped up in
response to this so that,
uh,
who's going to pay for this?
Well,
uh,
it's,
it's interesting that a,
so far I've been keeping track of,
of uh,
uh,
what the state expenditures have been
and what the federal government's
expenditures have been.
And,
uh,
right now we're close to a half a billion
dollars that's been spent on school
bus retrofits or,
or substituting the,
uh,
the,
lower emitting newer
engines for the older,
older engines so that requiring the
buses to use ultra low sulfur fuel at the
time the study came out was a
really important recommendation.
5,500 parts per million of software as
opposed to 15 parts per million of sulfur
produces a much,
much higher level of particulate matter.
So testing tailpipe emissions.
It's kind of interesting that that,
uh,
we have to have our cars,
tested for tailpipe emissions,
but trucks and buses generally do not,
uh,
so that,
they,
they are exempt.
In fact,
they can be pulled over on the highway,
uh,
and uh,
they can be asked by a department
of Environmental Protection,
uh,
working,
an employee working for the state,
uh,
to turn their engine on.
And they will hold what's
called a wrinkled chart up
against it that gives them
different levels of opacity and the hold
that up against the sky and visually
try to compare,
uh,
the darkness of the emissions to
their chart to figure out what,
whether or not they think that
the truck is in compliance.
Well,
this is not,
this is not the right way to go.
There should be much more,
a much more intense
and a precise estimate,
uh,
that,
we had the technology available to
conduct this kinds of emissions testing.
So,
uh,
the other thing to think here that is
important on this list is that the federal
standards,
the 15 micrograms per cubic meter
that is assuming a safe level,
uh,
what the safe threshold would be
with respect to outdoor pollution,
not with respect to within vehicle
pollution or other indoor sources,
uh,
being added on top of that.
So that,
you know,
my belief is that these federal standards
are not health protective because they
basically are looking at the problem as
a one source at a time or just measuring
what's going on in the outdoor environment
and forgetting that we spend 90% of
our time either indoors or,
or within vehicles.
Uh,
so we also clearly need to expand the
monitoring network and the idea that we're
getting our image of the intensity of
this kind of a problem by just relying on
fixed monitors outdoors,
it really makes little sense.
So putting monitors on individuals and
then following them through their daily
life,
that's,
that's going to give you a much
more accurate representation
of really what your
exposure and risk might be.
So this is a very expensive alternative.
Uh,
but it's likely to be
the wave of the future.
So the a second target for this
study has been state governments.
So what could state governments do that,
uh,
the federal government could not do?
Well,
they could,
they could prohibit a school
bus idling by statute.
And in fact,
uh,
when this study came out,
we proposed a law in Connecticut that
would demand a maximum of three minutes
for idling.
And since we did that,
there are 26 other states that
have adopted this same idea,
say fuel as well as reduce pollution.
So it's kind of a,
uh,
a double win situation.
So requiring buses to,
to,
uh,
also,
are requiring more buses to drive shorter
distances is another way of reducing
exposure.
So when most school districts like,
uh,
we're,
we're seeing today with respect to,
to declining state grants
and federal grants,
uh,
to,
to two school districts,
what are they doing there?
They're using fewer buses
and they're using their,
they're,
they're putting the kids on the buses for,
for longer periods of time.
So the roots are actually going in
the wrong direction leading to higher
exposures.
And finally,
local governments are really responsible
for enforcing these island bands.
And,
uh,
we found a couple of followup
studies that there's about,
there's about a 55 to 75% compliance rate,
uh,
for no island,
particularly at schools.
So now when we did this study,
all the buses would pull up and they'd
idle while a kids got on the buses or
they would idle as the kids got
off the buses to go into school.
Uh,
but now it's quite interesting.
The,
the,
the monitors here turned out not to be,
uh,
people that worked for the government,
but instead the school teachers,
cause the cu school teachers were,
were,
have long been angry.
I hadn't understood this,
but they were angry at the way that,
that,
uh,
the emissions were,
were making their way into the school.
And we found that many school systems
had their ventilation system set up so
that,
uh,
they were,
they were pulling the air from the
bus loading area into the school.
Uh,
and I had one superintendent tell me that,
that,
uh,
she always knew when the buses were,
were arriving,
uh,
even though she was 250 yards away from
where they were arriving on the other
side of the complex,
uh,
because the air ventilation system was
picking it up and redistributing it
throughout the entire school.
So just kind of thinking
about to a building design
as well as important also in
my own town and a response to this
because we did some of the testing and the
town,
when the town build a
new school two years ago,
it decided to create a staging area,
separate parking facility or buses
could go and instead of all the buses
training in at the same time,
we're all leaving at the same time,
they could stagger it so that,
uh,
you know,
when one bus is following another bus,
it's simply going to be
picking up the exhaust,
uh,
and distributing it.
So I wanted to give you just a sense
of a couple other kinds of air quality
problems that you may not have heard of.
This one was new to me.
I the,
there was a CNN reporter from,
uh,
who's,
who's beat as a Pentagon who called
me the other day and he said,
uh,
can you help me out?
Can you help me understand
what the threat is to,
uh,
people in the military
from open pit burning,
open pit,
burning of garbage.
Uh,
right now is,
is it prohibited in the United States,
although many people do it
in their backyard and open
pit burning is the primary
source of emission of
dioxins to the atmosphere.
So people on the right hand side of this,
uh,
in,
in a barrel will stuff their,
their garbage,
their waste into it,
and just burn it instead of having to,
to pay for a trash collector.
So you might save a,
you know,
$100 per month if you did this.
So,
so that,
uh,
what,
what's coming out is a product of
very low temperature combustion,
which is perfect for the formation
of dioxins and furans dioxins.
Some of the congeners are known to be
the most carcinogenic substances that we
are now aware of.
So that,
uh,
also you could think about how
pollution would kind of gather on,
on the surface nearby,
could gather on foods
or vegetable gardens,
but also kids playing in a sandbox.
So this is a kind of a
surprising source of,
of our exposure to dioxins
that are persistent
bioaccumulative and carcinogenic.
Uh,
there is a lawsuit that is
being considered by a group of,
of,
uh,
those in the,
air force,
uh,
that we're responsible for
maintaining these trash pits.
They're responsible to throw the garbage
in and you can imagine what their
exposure would be.
And what is the primary component
now of most of our waste?
Well,
it's turning out to be in terms of of,
uh,
a spatial volume rather than wait,
it's turning out to be plastics.
So plastics,
when they're burned,
particularly polyvinyl chloride,
is pretty well recognized to emit dioxins.
We have another phenomenon going on in
response to higher fossil fuel prices,
uh,
especially in the northern
latitudes in the country.
And these are wood boilers.
People are buying wood boilers
and basically not using their,
their furnaces,
they're natural gas furnaces or their,
their,
uh,
diesel fuel furnaces.
So that,
that,
uh,
these burn at a fairly,
low temperature and they also admit a
variety of pollutants including most of
the particles,
uh,
that,
in diameters that,
uh,
are,
are quite small,
just like tobacco smoke or
we're like a diesel emissions.
And here's just one
example of the effect of,
of,
of one household having a one wood burner.
And you can see this spreading
over an area that that,
uh,
is now,
at this point in the photograph,
uh,
it's about,
almost a half a mile wide and the
concentration of particulate in this area
because I've worked on woodsmoke smoke,
if you can see wood smoke at this level,
the particular concentrations
are likely to be,
uh,
in the,
many multiples above that
15 microgram federal limit.
So that this is a phenomenon that,
uh,
is increasing in prevalence and leading
to two really quite extreme exposures.
I know this firsthand because
I have a neighbor that,
uh,
installed one of these boilers and to,
he lives in a valley and I live
on the hill above the valley.
So every morning when the air is still,
because the sun has an
energize the atmosphere,
it builds up in the valley,
just like you can see in,
in,
in this case,
it takes a son too to a heat,
the atmosphere and basically
until about nine or 10 o'clock,
uh,
it,
it elevates,
but a,
our house is filled with wood
smoke from his house as an example.
And,
uh,
the,
the compounds in Woodsmoke are just as
dangerous as the compounds in tobacco.
You know,
one other kind of idea that a student
picked up on after this lecture a few
years ago was the idea of
mapping out healthy roots,
uh,
for exercise and urban environments.
I mean,
could you think about what the healthiest
route would be through new haven to
ride your bike or,
or to run?
I mean,
you certainly would want to run a,
say a in New York City within central
park where you would have much higher
quality than you would if you ran,
say along the Hudson River Parkway.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
could you map out the
healthiest running route?
Uh,
and,
uh,
the student did putting
our particle meters on a,
on a bicycle.
And,
uh,
one other thing that I'd like you to
think about that we're not going to have
much time to consider is,
you know,
the kinds of consumer,
uh,
behaviors that could,
could,
can lead to rather intense exposures.
You know,
whether or not it's the plugin fragrances,
uh,
the,
the car air fresheners.
And when I saw this,
and I mean everybody knows about these,
but the concept that,
uh,
you know,
you're sitting in traffic and you're
really bothered by diesel exhausts,
so you put up a car,
air freshener,
uh,
that submitting volatile
organic compounds that,
uh,
you may think are more pleasing
than the diesel exhaust,
but they are,
are largely untested.
They're,
they're completely unregulated.
Also the idea of aroma therapy,
uh,
not knowing what those compounds are,
fragrances.
Uh,
when we talk about plastics next week,
we'll,
we'll find that a,
there are plasticizers that are,
are hormonally active in,
in humans and many species of mammals,
uh,
that,
are components of some of the most
heavily used fragrances and also laundry
detergents.
And many people are experiencing
reactions to these fragrances.
And we're getting them in,
in mixtures that really are not,
uh,
not well understood.
So I'll leave you with that thinking that,
uh,
you know,
as you walk through your daily life,
uh,
think about ways you could modify your
behavior in a way that would reduce your
exposure.
Thank you very much.